there's way too much salt in American
diets even people who aren't susceptible
to hypertension are getting too much
salt and there's so much evidence that
salt is related to high blood pressure
and high blood pressure is related to a
whole host of chronic diseases coronary
heart disease stroke and so forth it
would be really terrific if we could cut
down on our salt intake we don't need
nearly as much as we're eating and the
real problem with it is that nearly
eighty percent of the salt and American
diets is there before anybody has any
choice about it it's either in the
processed food that we buy in the store
or it's in the restaurant food or the
food the pre-prepared meals that are
outside the amount that's added at the
table is minimal compared to what's
already there so what that means is that
for somebody who wants to cut down on
soul you can't eat processed foods and
you can't eat restaurant foods we need
to do something about that at the policy
level so that restaurants and processed
foods will cut down on the soul and make
it easier for people to eat less
there's a lot going on in government
right now trying to work with food
manufacturers and restaurants to cut
down New York City for example has a
very quiet under the table initiative to
try to get the salt and you see the
problem with salt is that if you're
eating a lot of it you don't notice the
taste of it you only notice the taste of
it if you're not eating a lot of it and
so if everybody in the population was
eating less then the foods that are out
there would taste terribly salty but
unless all of the food manufacturers and
all of the restaurants cut down at the
same time then nobody wants to go first
so that's really what the problem is
that's why you need government
intervention in this to try to make it
easier for people to cut down on their
salt intake because even if you want to
it's really hard